I'm excited I don't want to do this I
feel like I'm about to get physically
hurt I'm hoping that my Latin tastebuds
can take it I don't think it's gonna be
as bad as people told me before I am
gonna cry now
I've covered that it's good smells great
it smells like dried prunes and farts so
having them abeyance play I do it wrong
or something it's not that bad now dude
this is so bad
feels like Hornets are stinging my mouth
chew it up oh you have tissues my nose
oh my god I'm sweating
could I die this is my second Carolina
Reaper my team only gets worse like it
radiates spin thanks guys just like it
doesn't go away are you crying I'm
crying I feel like I did a line of like
glass maybe if I was about to die think
and just wanted it to go faster so I was
just like can poking needles in my
[ __ ] lip we were happier earlier and
now I'm on the bridge of Tears I feel
like if I sneeze a minute
be like a dragon like I'm fire right now
I am trying not to puke very hard but
the thing is like I'm so like prepared
for it I've had like other stuff that
just like hit me at the wrong time
are we once like wish this on my worst
enemy I would this would be a good one
for your worst enemy I thought for a
second I might die like first flips up
and I was like it's over so what just
happened I just do a bunch this is the
worst part